everybody and welcome to another FG
tutorial and in this video I'll be
showing you quickly how to get your old
version of Safari 3.2 point2 back now i
did a video recently on safari for beta
how to get it install it got 27 thousand
views and a lot of people have been
asking me commenting personal messaging
me how do i get safari 3.2 back they've
been dissatisfied they don't like it go
ahead and open up internet browser and i
will show you how to get safar 3.2 back
what we're going to do is go up here and
go to ww apple com ok and go up to their
search of their search bar at the top
right hand corner and just type in
safari and you'll see two things safari
4 and safari now safari is you're going
to click on the second one that says
downloads and just safari not
necessarily safari for now obviously
it'll come up and say safai for but if
you look down here it says are you
looking for safari three if so click
here so we're going to click that and it
will take us right to this page where
you can download any of the later or
earlier versions of Safari so you can
see here three point two point two three
point two point one all the way down to
version 1.3 point2 so all the older
version of Safari are here if you ever
want them same with the older versions
of itunes older versions of other
software that apple offers for download
on their website so just go ahead and
click on it download it it's a almost 50
megabytes I think it's a yeah 48
megabyte file okay this is for XP for
vista and you can get this in english as
well as a variety of other languages so
thanks for watching this HD tutorial i
hope this helped and if you have any
other questions or comments like i said
i will do a video like this on how to
answer and hopefully i can get back to
it as soon and as well as i can so
thanks for watching this one and stay
tuned for more peace
you